one of the biggest reasons struggled is
their offensive line continues to change
if you look at football teams a
consistent offensive line is one of the
great indicators to success because they
have to work in such a Unison with each
other I'm in the ad agency business
where people's tenure is about 18 months
I have multiple dozens of employees that
have worked for me for seven eight nine
ten years that's delivering for them not
only financially my dad always thought
that the money was solvent it's not bad
it's emotion it's relationships it's
putting people into new positions that
they're more interested in it's human
and so I spent my time on people I'm
trying to build a [__] Empire I have
to buy the Jets to win a Super Bowl
before I die